you know hey Skylar Astin but basically
before the this thing was running is
like I got glowing reviews don't ever
use the word glowing on this party
though glowing review alright only
positive reviews this guy well I saw her
victory is mine this is mine this guy's
got a voice he's good at plan an
American guy that's what I do and that's
my review voice of an angel of
Revelation the streets are talking my
streets I mean Broadway how many times
more times than I can count right that's
a [ __ ] obnoxious answer no ha what
have I done on Broadway is is more than
handsome that's an annoying 148 Tony
Awards I don't think you got a tie or
words did the show that I was original
character and get eight Tony Award
correct
yeah educate Brian from you would just
go don't joke like that man's a
helicopter of you should know on a very
real level only on 49th Street was I
like a member of the Beatles you know
for that time it was very exciting very
exciting it was before social media so
we were the Hamilton of them you know
become more Tony's in them though you
know if you wanna really Gail I think
yeah right yeah Alexander Hamilton
actually totally you could do it tell
him how did we tell them with that show
how they normally cast that role Oh with
somebody who is not quite quite why do
they call it but you're half-jewish what
do they call what white my know do my Rd
Jewish men are not considered yell out
of a white race class if you pick up a
history book you will [ __ ] realize
that Jews were probably killed and
kicked out of more countries than any
other race and they're the true minority
they make em 101 percent of the
population so to call a Jewish man a
[ __ ] white privilege male is offensive
it is up famous it is historically
offensive and ignorant
yeah and furthermore I want to isolate
even more of the audience um no
damnit I agree it's a tough but he likes
it look it's weird because being Jewish
like you or white we're white or whitish
coming soon too you know the network
near you
well you know Hollywood literally within
my grandmother's a lifetime there was
the little ditty called the Holocaust we
always have that how about the Russian
pogroms you don't want to get into it
but guys point is you know what Jewish
suffering yes I want to hear that now
all those Tony Awards what's bigger that
or you being the voice of branch on
trolls yeah that's what my son loves
what I really love about doing trolls is
I am so not judgmental when I watch it
like no matter what if I'm watching
myself it's it's always uncomfortable
but since it's not my face and they do
other things and nuances that they've
added I just enjoy the [ __ ] out of it so
for those of you you guys don't know
trolls the movie which was a super hit
Justin Timberlake was the voice of ranch
and Rick did and I cannot get the voice
of Poppaea
and then Netflix made it a series yeah
so there's a bunch of it's a grab so
don't try to jump in on this track so
then he's the voice they don't love it
so you don't know what they're so but
besides that Scott was the voice of
branch and for me my son literally loves
trolls and I'm I was so [ __ ] bored of
it and then he goes dude you're gonna
love it
I'm doing the troll series on Netflix
and I was every damn like when's he
coming out when is it coming out well
you come out and I definitely am NOT
allowed to say but we have so we have a
good number of episodes banked so it's
launched ah yeah a whole bunch
so the second drop comes out I think
next week so what it is is just a little
bit of math for you simple math it's
it's 622 minute episodes really what
that is is I believe 12 11 minute
episodes so each episode is two stories
like rug but I'm already bored because
it's about trolls I mean
millions people watch it
look I'm definitely uh the the parents
the dads and [ __ ] or like wait I
actually want to hear this this is more
trolls for my kid I didn't know that
that was there yeah yeah it's very
exciting and it's tying together who's
Ron Funches Ron Funches you know Ron Ron
he's brought a voice on the series or
yeah I was just in the booth with him
literally last Thursday I love that guy
yeah he's time on door and he talked to
it
David your roles really gelled yeah yeah
I'm like David Koechner fighter in the
kid alums on it Gary Cole Lumbergh from
the UH from office space
yeah it's great why I'm sorry that
animation is a tough gig right like I
was watching uh oh it's the funnest gig
no no see it's not a fun gig I'm saying
it's so competitive tough to break
through yes because like boss baby's
huge right now right but you look at the
names and splitting the biggest names in
the world get those roles yeah but not
so much on like Disney or Nickelodeon or
in the Moana how dare are you know but
you're talking features I'm talking
features I'm talking series it's a
little different there's there's so many
unsung heroes that you on there for sure
but are legends in features those true
like free to wolf there's this other guy
named Kevin who literally is just like
they're like my buddy Arnie who who is a
huge it he loves voiceover but he's a
big nerd for it so he understands he's
like you're working with him oh my god
they do everything they do the Kung Fu
Panda series they do like they could
voice match anything they're just these
like who is the originals Luke Skywalker
Mark Hamill yeah Mark and he does a lot
of he does the Joker on like a bet oh
really has a bunch of buddies with him
and now I do it on a different kind of a
situation with the Netflix and the
DreamWorks of it all but you guys aren't
all in the same studio right like knock
when he was doing Moana didn't meet the
girl like until later at the office
you don't mean if my wife and I are
about to be on a show called vamp arena
which is like a Disney thing or whatever
i watch marina below tonight we're gonna
play it's on Disney so I just do these
like and it takes like an hour we've
seen a song together but we net we we
were both in New York doing plays but
with our schedules yes to make out in
the booth all the time over ten we go to
record and no we actually recorded
separately so like we did a duet we just
heard it but we weren't in the booth at
the same time you know ten years ago I
used to be part of with ICM at the time
they were the biggest voice of before
the strike destroyed everything but like
12 years ago ICM was the place right and
so well because you just have these like
you'd see these actors that would come
in and do voiceovers like everybody from
like I mean it'd just be lazy yeah it
was a big one for voice yeah I was
Buckwald when I was doing Spring
Awakening which won eight Tony's a what
about Jane Leeves before anybody knew
her huge we'd always be in the boots
we'd all be waiting you go in and read
your thing and Verizon you got to do it
in she's she's in wreck-it Ralph Jane
Jane are you in the new record part two
- no I mean I'm in the first one but I
know that I should I don't know where
they even recording okay we're doing a
part two I know they're definitely doing
a part two but there might not ya think
no no if I'm gonna do it I'm probably
gonna do like a fun or small role and
those things don't really happen until
like common sense I don't know please do
please do Alton you can do it here right
now the body stuffed in here [ __ ] do you
know the words um no but I did know more
of the words too in the heights and I
would do it for the Spring Awakening
cast I would do a kind of linman well I
really think that's an amazing role for
you the lin-manuel can we be honest
though scholar the biggest thing you've
ever done the intro for below the belt
dude let's talk can we play that for
them come on we like to play that for a
second for sure whatever set it airs
tomorrow so good yeah there's too much
what do I say to you when I text you
Skyler so talented and today at Showtime
I film my first episode never was like
that's guy I gave you props you [ __ ]
they're like how much in there just
talking when all this stuff my teeth how
much did you pay anything you a bag of
gummy bear
you know he did it he's a good three for
me too I don't give a [ __ ] I've done
your dad's birthday songs too
oh that's right okay last time though
hey for sure yeah yeah I'll definitely
do that a bunch of stuff and he just
wrote it I was like Jesus Christ
Josey my the tale of a man will be
Michael Kelly below the belt we
literally had an animation I said to
Scott Lee hey can you help me out with a
song and like the next days like here it
is this one I'm thinking I sent to the
Showtime like holy [ __ ]
yeah man home voice of the angel I don't
want to pack my own back but your
producer Gabe he kind of he's the best
by the way awesome he but he kind of he
just was on such a deadline that I
didn't understand like not understand
how quickly chin and I I mean shame you
can attest like it was insane and and
chin made it all [ __ ] happen by the
way chin worked like he was making
iPhones an apple that shins literally he
worked all weekend yeah a literally I
mean all of this raw stuff a lot of like
you know obviously I wrote the lyrics
and the melody and I and I without Scott
it doesn't happen does not happen right
but I don't have the sounds again sir to
accept an award for real resources just
this room that we're in right now
everybody breaking the fourth wall in
Playa Vista like this is not set up to
do what we did in here but we just have
good enough mics and chin works the chit
and and we just rally free j-turn trip
into quiet soldier [ __ ] nice
and quiet he kills people on the
weekends here's a quiet soldier circular
chin the quiet changing you play that
song you guys did for yeah yeah
and cap port Ron in the face woke up
with a baby puke all over the place
[Music]
so right for this makeup on my face
begins to melt its
oh damn your voice is so [ __ ] good
voice of an angel
hey you want to know it's funny about
that actually like a little inside
baseball about why it speeds up at the
end and why there's that like little gap
there the song is actually original
supposed to be like trader foot both of
them back in and gap Andrade in the face
woke up with a baby
so it's supposed to be very in the
pocket yeah very done and then like I
wrote it to have like big brass horns
and like ideally like three backup
singers like who who you know whatever
but we had to we had to marry it to the
animation which you guys will see on the
intros morning tomorrow morning yeah so
so I had to actually like they came to
me it's very backwards because normally
I would just write a song they'd animate
it yeah and like it would and then I
would tweak some things but actually
this was a finished animation and it
didn't time out perfectly so we had to
anyway we just had to move some stuff
over not in post-production actually in
the construction the final products I
saw this afternoon it's so solid and
it's so professional but also just to
know like the limited and just the
amount of kind of favors and how quickly
it came together that's when it always
feels like it's powerful team why don't
you have just an animation of my face
just like hey like because Brian's not
involved in what we're talking about I
was waiting for it exactly do you know
it's weird today I don't know you guys
grew up on sets I've ever been on sets
especially when it's like your show and
I got there early you know the hashtag
crazy-ass wake up time and I'm sitting
there everyone keep going do you need
anything
are you good are you good I went hey
quit asking me that I want who do you
typically work for I'm not Ryan Seacrest
like just chill Mary wants let me just
do my thing yeah that's just everyone's
good man yeah I'm swear I'm fine dude of
coffee let's go yeah that's all coffee
and breakfast if it's like a set and
there's like that's your only food cuz
nothing else is toffee nobody fart on
set rule number one name nobody farting
on there you just make really outrageous
demands but you just pink starburst I
take a coconut with two straws please
organic remember we're filling finally
kid 3d and you flipped out on her freak
out on us just his name was Justin
Cheney's a good guy Justin change is a
great time I just talked to another not
to be confused justin chon who played
Jeff Chang in 21 and over
and not with Jackie Chan or Tom or to
the guy named okay or two all right we
avoided it nice let's go to our man
wifey's good wife he's great renovating
the bathroom oh great Oh fans names our
hold on heated toilets a day in a dryer
but I like it I said you want to clean
your ron paul process hold on let me if
your whistle corny talking about bad a
real quick Bryan Callen will make
whatever sink he finds in a restaurant
for taking [ __ ] up a day no wow you
won't feel the Bryan Bryan at comedy
clubs will get on the water splashes ass
what are you doing he goes gotta clean
your whistle man yo that's not a bidet
we wash our hands you wanna pop up and
just take the water your bra you really
do that because there's no there's no
you do that but if it's what are you
[ __ ] Chris Kattan I was wrong you
don't do that so much
no no you psychopath while my ass clean
I'll taste like I was at that you want
her glass is not my thing I wanted to
squirt a freaking stream up my ass I was
at the [ __ ] cloud nice clean walk I
was in a comedy club I took a [ __ ] and I
jumped up on the sink I know I've seen
that I began to wash my in the to know
the waitress were you oh you were
capping obvious you're talking no no you
read a restaurant oh you're a psychopath
no I wouldn't do it at a restaurant cuz
that's something what did the way just
say I I was up with my this thing about
embarrassing this here I asked my
[ __ ]
I'm in your big boy
oh it's ready I think you have to say
it's already terrible it's already kind
of like a secret right second of my well
she comes in she walks in and people are
leaving so as they're walking out my
fans can see that I'm sitting with my
father but she opened the door and saw
me and she was waitin fer day and she
looked at me in a and closed the door
immediately and I jumped off and I never
spoke about it and I bet you she never
spoke about it either brah Kylie does
you think she told everybody hey I would
buy cars Ryan basically [ __ ] in the
city was washing try to push it down
like he's making french fries out of
potatoes I wipe it very well I just make
sure that it's very my whistles cleaned
so dried [ __ ] in the sink hey you know
what you are you were the kid when
you're taking a piss in elementary you
put your pants all the way down I don't
want a dirty I can't have [ __ ] on my
yeah I knew I was like that so straight
as Aaron of course there's always one
hey Brian here's the thing I'm so
disappointed because well because it's
it is you're a filthy disgusting animal
slightly on branch
so my question no one's surprise yeah
like your fans you should have said
something
you should have owned it yeah this is
what I did probably know that I don't
have any secrets we basically aired
everything out either Rogen on board the
vodka ever say like you know yeah I
don't well this is our thing at least
like right well can you work at box and
burn now you just show me does your
train there
same color a shirt my arms a 5/8 box is
that a medium on you oh no it was
definitely in that shirt I have I no
pound-for-pound how much better I look
in that chair taking my own brain and
maybe however I lean though you have a
great TV body he does maybe how about
today on have it Kenny when we're
getting ice cream we saw that that
couple oh this is great and yeah oh he
goes he can talk about the Porsche
experience he the guy brought his wife
down to birthday and then we're talking
really nice couple he goes he goes let
us know when you're I go it's not about
levity life cuz I'm there you go swab
will come and show in let me live I'm
like yeah I'm there March 16th 70s to
you guys there the bride goes oh yeah I
might be yeah you guys try to make it up
there to and I go I will bro I will say
any guys shut up Brian you don't know
and he goes yeah I do
shut up right now just [ __ ] and so
Brian
shoutout to that day it was so funny
shut up your [ __ ] listen every
episode of every episode you know
everything about me yeah you know is
that great so does Evo do it is great
let me keep it in the room a lot I want
that purple stop wait wait you know what
I'm gonna give the ultimate fan
experiences because you know what I even
though I I'm not even in the top three
for guests of the gear I get you guys
you wanna know why man I'll tell you
what
chin chin it's not chin specially made
the list feel Vaughn on in like November
I'm on like briefly in June in between
not sad because up I'm in February like
yours think I'm softening the beach
we're like the Oscars bro you have come
in late man you want the word dare you
it's a political I'm not campaigning for
this this means nothing to me we'll have
you back nothing let me back with the
next year when it's closer to voting
yeah if I'm available [ __ ] let me let me
explain something I don't need you like
right now I'm doing a favor
hey I'm doing a favor for you guys hi
bean girl right now no literally I feel
like you moved in New York and then you
haven't been
you ever that's what you were living
that girl use on Broadway try your
[ __ ] act together hey God it's called
what we're up against oh wait this is
actually fascinating it was this play
called what we're up against by Theresa
Rebeck
a dark comedy set in the 1990s
architects love remix work right
nineteen nineties one of the year yeah
it was it's now a period piece guys I
had the whole Zack Morris like but
growing up look but like but fun no
because I was in an office I was but I
had like the Michael J Fox I had like a
cassette tape and like drumsticks and my
work I was a real dick what it is is
about gender politics in the workplace
so I was over eighteen ninety a night
yeah it was freeze the Wild West yeah in
in-between like we're like everyone
still drinks whiskey but we're not mad
man we're not smoking and drinking
inside but like you know a lot of the
thing takes place with me and my boss
drinking whiskey it's it's it's it's
looser the music's fun it's like you
worked at vice yeah I mean it was an
architecture firm so that joke some guy
got it okay I'm with Harry disappoint
you know I see him every morning I walk
my kids Shane yes hmm I used to be like
that guys like the most manly he's like
more of a man than I could ever be
he still is you just like snow yeah he
just likes to be weird he's [ __ ]
weird guys why is everyone rubbing their
dick on everything all right it's
ridiculous
you're the last guy in the world that's
ever gonna know and that's why I walking
around with a clean conscience I guess
has an accusation but nothing's of
complete shocker guy yet and also it's
out a couple yeah but with Ryan secrets
they did a whole investigation they
didn't find anything
what about talking a third party
investigation found than enough there
what about louis c.k man it's [ __ ]
insane i know we're talking about
current events from everything i know
you guys know that's a very strange
thing here i tase back in the year or
two years of an event no way and i bet
you he drops by about this way he's
gonna be very sure he's gonna shoot on
it he's gonna like i was the worst
person the worst it happy new years
never worse than me i was condemned like
in its and was gonna be cracking up
because it's gonna be at madison square
finally yeah he'll find a way to deal
with it in the best way because his
wasn't
look no it's all awful but it's it's not
like you know there are certain people
that are rotting in hell and there are
certain people that need to come to
grips he's got a weird some people have
so I think there's difference between
being a predator and a rapist and all
that another weird fed in there people
have weird fetishes and like who who get
off on that we are like you're just like
it's like for louis c.k like Harvey
Weinstein I go like this I'm calling the
police
carisi yeah I go dude we had friends
yeah like your phone's like bro brides
jacking off from people for Tommy story
go what are you doing yeah do to stop
doing this right leg goes wrong with you
even even before the YouTube way before
baby it's gonna can you do this together
yeah that's yeah exactly it's just it's
really hard from a moral standpoint has
your wife dealt with any of that
I'm sure she's beautiful and she's in
Hollywood I'll let her she's away it's
perfect no I'm so don't you dare no look
she's extremely talented every you know
there there's been look I'm not speaking
on her behalf at all because that's her
story to tell she doesn't have anything
obviously or else you would have heard
about it literally the stuff of like a
[ __ ] meeting at 6 p.m. at the Chateau
Marmont career drinks and you're like
why am I work there like yeah I've
always cringed at I'll never forget this
there there was always this idea that
you know when you're with the guys
you're hunting your hun you're going to
pick up construction I never liked that
[ __ ] right because it always because
with the way I felt was your preying on
people with low self-esteem and whatever
is gonna happen cheap joke it's like
also like the culture we have a culture
to all no you're joking
we have a culture like I watched this
thing on Howard Stern and I never forgot
this and they had women with great
bodies and ugly faces and so they had
men lined up including Howard Stern and
that have a girl come out in a bikini
she had a great body and they had a
paper bag of her head and they would
take it off and she'd be she'd have
hopefully a quote unquote ugly face and
they'd all go there oh and they oh my
god and they give her a score and this
was watched double channel
brother but but I think that I think
that I'm bringing to anybody so far so
sign up for that okay so you're always
gonna find very low self-esteem people
to think of themselves peace [ __ ]
I don't want to lend myself to that yes
of course you don't want to subscribe or
you're always willing to be [ __ ] [ __ ] on
because of the trauma they went through
or whatever or beat up or even killed I
mean this is how human beings are but it
doesn't mean I have to lend myself to
you're just further destruction and I
remember just thinking to myself that
kind of [ __ ] just makes Howard Stern
couldn't do a show today if you not do a
shout show what he got pull off for
comedy I'm just not out surge brilliant
but the way he got to where he got you
know yeah we all paid attention to
kisser you know I did push the envelope
what I wanna watch but what I want to do
like these days what I did this weekend
very stressful week very busy or why are
you busy no some very people got you
yeah you talking about in here when you
weren't recording look you guys are
crushing I'm very proud of both you so
you young kids have no respect you know
believable mimicking young kids human
how old you know 30 Steve nearly 30 I'm
20 or brother 32 and my younger brother
Yanni's I'm a full legal human older
than you yeah I'm 21 years older that's
right so you listen to everything I said
your wife he's just grinding she's
always doing like big movies she's like
legit play out here like on like one of
her like she's so excited about it too
at the Pasadena Playhouse she her and
Tommy Sadowski a two-hander like this
really dark like dramatic she's just
like once a sinker one hugs ain't going
to that but she was on Broadway also she
we're both were just there and like the
amount of people for yesterday she
Instagram that she's she's doing this
thing and she's like she never talks it
or gloats or brags ever so understated
and she turned to me and Ben she's like
honey
people have reached out to me today that
are so excited to see this play I'm like
what I'm in and I'm like yeah cuz did we
always go off to new you guys card and
go no no I was really tailored okay oh
no you know what I was doing well let me
take out my earplugs because 1459 to the
story bro are you I got to start doing
this in this people room is so sick oh
you're that busy it's hard for me to
work out now I woke up at have someone
work out I wish I woke up on would it
stay when I woke up on Monday 15 hours I
woke up on Monday at 5:00 a.m. so I
could run in the morning so I get my
work at it dude I know holders that I'm
like how do you do it man like I have
buddies that Brenton Thwaites and well I
was doing that war movie I worked out a
lot I went to box and burn a lot before
I remember who there more than me
because I was doing a war movie so I
needed to get my chest up a little bit
but these guys kept it going and I just
like by the end you know it's like
drawing a lot of close to so I was never
like shirtless or anything like that but
so once I realize like I'm [ __ ]
wearing the helmet and doing leather
right and the Bulgarian food is all just
meat bread and cheese
you know I know those guys still did it
though I don't know how I need to figure
some 15 hour days in dirty ass Bulgaria
with gear and my back and I'm just like
nothing none of that my resources that
are here I'm in a communist should I
should have found a wrestling club and
just joined it hey I got a pool loves
boxing gym how about that we got us like
sure they were seated are you there dude
he just kept telling me I don't know how
to throw a 1 and 2 when I'm pulling my
cross it's a related appétit I adapt it
to their style it was fine my second
session was a lot better say you adapted
to anybody's boxing styles gonna make me
crazy what are you talking about I'm a
trained dancer how dare you you man
do your best choreography one of the
eight Tony's no joke dancing and singing
is I tried that once
I had to fill in for a [ __ ] for
somebody and they say can you carry it
too and I said you know a shower singer
and I I he was good though we talked
about this is [ __ ] good I was there
no no this is
actually no you're thinking something
different this was a musical I did I
actually did a musical oh really
yes and what I do is I sang spoke it
kind of like a guy just talks of it it
was an original piece and it's our
original piece uniform for Ron Rifkin
Bradley Cooper [ __ ] it was a scene in
acting class that you have to sing for
once workshop in New York I had to do
dance moves and I had to listen to the
music and follow it and if you don't
know how to do that
yet for you second nature for me it did
dancing and singing and you're like how
is she I mean and that's another level
to I mean but yeah I've had to do like
that kind of cardio while blasting out
us I know it's a different type of shape
or or running all over a stage and a big
character piece like this thing I just
did in New York if your girl could just
give me that Pasadena Playhouse some
meathead role if made me do what you use
achill not all sing in the back walking
a dog in the background that's my
pussycat whoa whoa hey Brennan unit
that's you can't sing that you don't
have any line right you still have to do
that is there the comedian still we're
comedians do rock music or they perform
like a crime do it yeah why did you know
who are you I told you
you sound like that guy who the [ __ ]
it's exhausting cries I sang mother by
danzig it was a [ __ ] good man I
record it remember consider that song I
think you'd crush it listen to it maybe
do a cut-down version of it cuz it's
long I can a little bit sing like Baba
O'Riley by Roger Daltrey like I yeah
right it's in my tone so I can fake it
this is a huge you're in hand shirt off
Bryan Callen okay
we could do a lip sync battle did you do
lipstick i won
I hope I'm lip singing you can actually
fuzzy winning yeah yeah green one
tweeted at me this is everything a
[ __ ] well she does use she's lost
all music crowd is when she had that
song milf money out that was kind of
number one and I deal that song milf
money which is a viral video exact it
was huge how does that go uh you got
it's like you know how do you win them
both all right on milkshake I was like
dressed like as a milkmaid or some [ __ ]
he killed it him and Chris D'Elia both
killed it Oh Christus oh we came back
people are like Oh Brian Britt and go on
lifting bad I'm like Brian would see I'd
have to get super creative oh no people
I went against [ __ ] Rana or Metta
World Peace they love the athletes you
when Shaq goes on there it's that's your
you kidding me are you kidding me dude
did you get creative thing they they
build a set you there they it's Tim
Tebow expected I had to work harder
because I did like a Bieber thing for
the first round that's very like okay
like that when I saw your online like my
gays gonna [ __ ] kill but they kind of
swayed towards the athlete don't they
yeah but I want him yeah I was everybody
Chris didn't we to eat them starchy and
husband Brad Morris applause actually
Chris will be happy that I'm telling
this story into a flip if they did it
and then he never did the backflip
yeah that's dirty player I love bread
though the watch his [ __ ] moves Chris
well he moves like look at him he's the
first person you get cool for this ever
right so [ __ ]
he was like in his third season or his
sitcom - he was so loose he's trying not
to let him what Just Dance Ruth the body
is actually an amazing dancer I'm
looking up he's read it very limb he's
so [ __ ] talented dude he went like
viral with that without dancing the real
[ __ ] yeah look at this we got
talented he is you forget how this we
[ __ ] around with them all time you
forget how talented [ __ ] look this is
him being silly instead [ __ ] these
trains and for rational idiot he is like
a fan belt by those yeah it's crazy
well now Christine Tegan's I'm not mad
at at all so nice I met guys doing -
dude it's so stupid his skinny legs
[Laughter]
LL Cool J he's shut that place down you
tell me you should have [ __ ] won a
hundred percent
oh my Shive one might be the best
performance on I never saw this I
watched your life is better than mine I
think mine was just fun Bri can you
bring up scowers wait so let me tell you
something l Cool J so he's so as
advertised because he he knows like the
more it goes well like healed the Hobie
cut two more it's like he I mean he's
very like in a great mood he's like
isn't this amazing like yo like just so
hyped on it and but the whole thing is
when the other person goes yeah because
it's clearly pulling but he's playing
the role of LL Cool J no way but he but
then when it was like really the cameras
were off we talked about boxing
to fight we have the same manager right
yeah he's been with him since he was 21
and he was telling me about this time
this is fairly recent when a dude broke
in LL Cool J's house and LL Cool J
caught him he's built like you wife had
this whole my family first break he's a
big strong mother I don't know if they
have his first hello oh this is great
now could they've given you an easy
today I've given you the answer man to
beat yeah how great was Chris on that
I'll go back that's it I love it I love
my room go both of us it'd be fun we
should I told you my managers good what
an astonishing looking man he is my way
know about what the [ __ ] is this oh my
god Skyler
no Skyler tears it up hold on well the
fans be able to see this at home I got
to chop it up oh my god hon I'm the boat
I'm the most unattractive girl ever I
also made sure to not shave anything I
wanted to be the hairiest woman ever oh
my god beast now how much time do you
have to rehearse this are they literally
teaches to you in like an hour and film
the whole thing so you're like look at
this Oh My Damn Oh what you learn this
yeah but how is it a week of rehearsal
always literally one hour you know about
what it is like I like came up with
ideas but actual choreography they teach
these dancers like an hour before
basically I come in and they're like
yeah whatever you could retain and it's
all on camera so it's like yo I'm on a
reality show I'm like hey could you turn
the cameras off just while I'm like
learning cuz like it's not gonna be good
stuff but yeah so you just kinda have to
go for it and you're like what are these
words but you know the words
yeah book is a lot of people well I've
done a lot of lip-syncing but like Glee
and pitch perfect and stuff they get on
you people always the second they start
dancing they forget to you know they're
like oh [ __ ] they're like yo you're not
moving your mouth you're just trying to
remember you're pouring milk on yourself
that's [ __ ] great
how stupid how dumb he's up cross your
performer of course yeah no that's just
a good shake you know what I'm most
excited about though now my so I have to
Teen Choice Awards which if people don't
know their surfboards so am i man cave I
have to Teen Choice Awards you're dope -
golden popcorn MTV Movie Awards for a
pitch-perfect one and two and then this
hasn't come yet
but it will and it's like a you know how
much of a mark I am for WWE it's like a
legit WWE like the guy that makes the
WWE belt so it's like it's pretty good a
belt go from belt oh yeah so give me a
break dude you know work out for that so
are you gonna freak out on below the
belt you know we're covering WWE - I
might be going to Wrestlemania
are you really covering that - dude do
you know how balls-deep I am in that I
know I need to talk to you about it I'll
go do me you in stone cold need to story
we got stone cold on the show and March
he's the listen to it yeah oh wait I'm
below the belt oh hello the belt we're
coming dude I am very excited we to meet
him I mean I met him once but like I
wanna like it human Robert Lee and Trey
human you guys cuz he's a piece well he
lives here
Vegas oldest place in Texas we just want
please go he's 100% 100% on the Mount
Rushmore of mine it's funny - really -
Larry would you got who's your on your
mush it's tough and a lot it's a that's
a big one to say yeah let's see it dude
you three you ready for mine three three
well mount rest was four and five four
so four you ready you're gonna say Ric
Flair Ric Flair gorgeous Gorge ready
old-school Ric Flair gorgeous Gorge
Macho Man Randy Savage
Hulk Hogan what's up doc is Andre the
Giant only have one person that's the
same so here's the deal
in my opinion the Mount Rushmore
conversation starts chapter snake know
after the territory age because it's
hard there was no there was I knew that
root is the barber be can the snake
stable no Jake the snake Roberts is a
Famer have you seen the documentary and
hopefully seen there's like three make
you cry yeah dude big not big some her
great
well that's cake no cons got to dude
there's like a berry on the stuff so my
Mount Rushmore I think it actually just
starts with the WWF taking over the
territories the NWA to WCW I it's all
now a part of the WWE Hall of Fame that
it's all double y WS not pro wrestling
anymore they are a monopoly I mean
there's always an indie scene but so Ric
Flair III only I have to kick them off
only because in the WWE I know and I saw
the documentary and I have so much
respect for me is one of the greatest
but I'm thinking just in the career of
the WWE I just have to know I wish there
were five places because takers should
be on there the Undertaker mm-hmm a Hulk
Hogan of course Stone Cold Steve Austin
and then there's like the rock John Cena
Undertaker Shawn Michaels Bret Hart
that's you know that's a whole depending
on what we time how about the Big Show
gravitation the big he's like holding
the mountain up no warrior macho man on
there absolutely not
I went to macho man's wedding by the way
SummerSlam 91 Elizabeth will you marry
me oh yeah so weakly dude I love him
what do you think about Rana being the
WWE I thought her debut was clunky
because she didn't really have a strong
point of view rough but last night she
got my stuff and that was two nights ago
at Elimination Chamber I think that she
was very focused and it was great in a
second I think the segment was way too
wordy for no reason it could have been
way streamlined I think with her and you
you guys who knows also her first line
sorry in double w-where hi guys yes
no I my thing is though you know she's a
great as far as like competitor stuff
like that but people forget the rock and
like stone
old and these Undertaker are straight
performers I just reason the rocks last
summer Moorhead there were just fell
into Hollywood performance is a very
different and better every single time
yeah she still is a long way to go see
they're putting her in a really
comfortable storyline and it's playing
out while any shoes with the best in the
bit I would make her a heel they will
and they should make I completely make
yeah I will start her and she looks so
much easier for know you got a starter
as a babyface and then turn her and then
she turns back do you they literally
Hudson or you can't bring her in without
being grateful I wish they did but
that's too much about cuz she's gonna
handle the hey it's not but yeah she
can't handle the hey she needs to she
needs to let through now to run on her
and then she turns on the crowd then she
turns heel and then they you have to
turn heel you don't just come in as if
you really rot the rock came in as Rocky
Maivia and then they were shooting die
Rocky die chance and also on the rock
and then they love the rocky turn right
back to a face yeah can I see some rock
rocky maivia pull him up in the with the
blue with the rocky wasn't always like
the many died from a bad guy yeah Rocky
ro these liar doesn't his dad was a big
time his dad no
I saw a picture and I say I can't work
I'd like to get on that right
classic no that's weird what if I could
get on that rock died do you know what's
taken of me maybe the Rocky Maivia
steroids and he's as chewables though I
know I need the exact kind of well let
me cut up in his veins and after I peel
through the green he is pretty jacked
maybe I just Rocky Maivia rear when Rock
first got to Hollywood we get all skinny
but when you're Marilyn Rock first got
to Hollywood n't get real thin no oh wow
pictures yeah in first went Hollywood he
got super mummy like to 2230 I was he
thought that's what they wanted be right
bro yourself Jackie eight in the here's
Rocky Maivia now I'm so happy to be here
there he is
he's on like the Saturday morning WWF
superstars v juice and then too
sure this was the era where he's so
[ __ ] amazing
you ever see him sing and play up the
piano yeah he used to play guitars in
segments on WWE dude he's uh he's the
real deal
so he's on the Rushmore he's gotta be I
mean but you know the in honky Tonk Man
on commentary get out of here this is
great keep this on the fast food
Brendan's checking his phone you're
poreless or what no they're watching
this is happening I'm gonna start
watching yeah but I listen to your show
I don't I don't watch it I listen to it
in the car
there's a bunch of people driving truck
moving machinery we need to keep them
upright I agree they're not watching him
fight the blue meanie or whoever this
guy is dr. X hey check out dr. X's look
hey by the way Brendan we need to do a
like fun little wrestling companion I
agree for the W yeah and you get Sasso
Sasso knows his wrestling media knows I
know
I've listened to him on many you know
your wrist I really know it men I'm
going on the masked man show tomorrow so
it actually debuts the same you've been
watching this since you were a kid yes
but I took a long separation when I was
like you know a dude in my teens and 20s
you know I took a break and then like
came back to it and kind of like a more
like nostalgic sense with the WWE
Network and then got into it and now
there's like a layer of irony that's on
top of it too and like you start to
fantasy book and it becomes like like
Bill Simmons people that's who I'm doing
it with tomorrow they're very like the
ringer the other ringer so those guys
David shoemaker who did the Andre the
Giant documentary comes out in April
exactly dude they're about to blow up
you know this yeah I can't wait for that
but Mauro Ranallo
you know who does show I do showdown
with yeah he's a documentary coming out
about mental health yeah they sent me
the trailer I can't show it anything
that they send me the trailer sure it
was it's the most intense thing I've
ever seen I was like what what
depression does how was that cuz you
know him yeah I've never documented that
he's
dark inside arts like yes you do Mamma
Mia
he obviously called Ronda Rousey's first
fight that's right okay okay yeah yeah
he suffers from depression horrible
horrible but the they show me start
using an insane asylum when he's younger
why his best friend died he just like do
not want first in line for this I mean
tragically do you see the document I was
like oh my god they show him hopefully
and talk about you senator yeah
they show him like after you starting
announcing the Floyd Mayweather Conor
fight and he's back in his room he's
reading the waiter and he goes if they
don't like it then why just [ __ ] kill
myself oh my god yeah you know I ain't
on he is the nicest man in my world oh
and not to mention he's been doing since
he was 14
he's a savant you can go hey what fight
was in Pride in 1999 Japan and he'll go
in a rip through the whole card and also
give you Japan pro-wrestling to like how
does he have so much it for me you know
he's doing WrestleMania yeah
oh then go van Gogh used to suffer from
depression he would be in is he doing
the cruiserweight class he has something
to do with it that's great I'm glad that
if they're in closes do more because he
had the SmackDown thing and he like what
you know some of this kind of stuff is
so debilitating you can't get out of bed
like like for months like soso van Gogh
would be in bed for two three months at
a time and then when he'd come out of it
he knew he had to paint everything
before he's and go back yeah he knew
he's gonna go back in so he just knew it
was gonna come hit him be do you tell to
these people okay Mauro's I was talking
about the fire
Brook cut off your ear relax yeah hey do
you think it's because I feel like now
it's more prevalent than ever do you
think it's a case of just awareness or
do you think with its society you know
I'm saying what's that like when I was a
kid no kids were really committing
suicide no kids had mental health issues
but now it's like if well I think they
were and they did I think we just didn't
[ __ ] clear I wasn't saying chill out
to mental health no you were talking
about van Gogh sleeping for months
you're a suicide because I just heard it
it's nuanced in your in everything you
do you're tough let's go down with
Skyler down oh we should kill bad ain't
it funny how we have to all be careful
about what we say yeah well I mean I
thought this comedian space so you can
trust tree but you thought you in the
trust tree with a big gate out
chill out well you know what to that
point [ __ ] they were talking about
Chris Cornell Rogen and Jocko Willick
we're talking about Chris Cornell kill
himself and there you know a lot of
times they've done a lot of sighs I'm
like your serotonin level is set at a
certain point so if you're lucky enough
to have a serotonin lemon let's at seven
no matter what you know they say you
could be win the lottery you can find a
cure for cancer and your serotonin level
will go right back to four if that's
where you're at so we all have a set
point weight out of ten you're saying
yeah oh so you went out of yours at ten
yes and you you you two we're both
pretty hot data utility yeah yeah I'm
pretty lucky that we have raised the
four yeah but for the most part your set
point is that and they've done Studies
on this where people become paraplegics
and they it's a devastating thing and
about six months after a devastating
accident Jonathan hi stun ought to work
on this no matter what you go back to
you know your real back yeah you go back
to [ __ ] it you know this is it but I'm
still blessed because of this whereas
people who are depressed they you know
it's it's a certain things are worse
yeah man it's a [ __ ] hard
state to be in I can't imagine well you
know you guys make formulas like on 16
and pregnant the og series I watched
imam oj do Teen Mom last night
the girl on there she had a miscarriage
and you know that's actually a spoiler
alert no it's happened happen last night
Kaitlyn had a miscarriage you serious
but she choked him in suicide and they
had to check her into rehab she's off
the show right now are you and so serifs
Affairs option for doing pornos way
dance the thing is about her is um she's
a psycho those girls that girl rotten a
rotten apple dr. Drew was I do you look
at her eyes and she's she looks like a
great wife era yeah yeah dude everything
she's mother let's not do that I just
see the way she talks to the producers
on the show they're like you can't you
got to stop talking people like this
like you can't treat people like this
it's all I mean they found out she doing
webcams like she did porno before and
then she apologized they let her back on
the show now they find out she's doing
webcams like see me go anal this tonight
am i oh I can't fast-forward through her
storylines line I mean I like Catelynn
and Tyler though their I like Tyler's a
little beast our listeners like [ __ ] you
too right now to statement you wonder if
they're like renovates this whole house
by himself he's more of a man's do you
watch this - yeah dude this is how I
chill I don't watch acting I'm a [ __ ]
snob tell you right I don't want to
watch some [ __ ] I actually I can't I
don't want to watch a lot of stuff
that's on TV because you know it's just
your friend you know you're just like
whatever that is gets in it like gay
teen mom I know how much yeah yeah teen
mom or the best [ __ ] out there [ __ ]
Game of Thrones or dark series on
Netflix yeah okay yeah but I watch
baskets you see baskets that shit's
funny to me Anderson saw a couple of
Louie Anderson is so amazed amazing
really places the mother is so good and
Zach alpha knack is in being a woman
marathon is I've seen Louie an aside to
show with him and he in his stand-up
cryed cryed about his mother but it was
all funny and he's just so theatrical
and then came out of it he's a mom's
like dude you just [ __ ] on it you
just cried for real and by the way it
was a benefit for a battered women and
he cried about how his mother protected
he and I think his brother Rama his
father who used to hit them can be this
and dude he started crying but the way
he did it and then he came back into
comedy came true into the facts
what he does on the shuttle so good I
was like Lois you're so amazing he
talked to me he said he watched me and
he said you'll when you get you you was
very nice they said when you decide to
get even more real you'll bring them to
their knees and I was like I'm not gonna
cry like that but thank you
but he's amazing man he's great he's all
around the commies
as far as like his old I don't know how
he is as a dude but like just my wife
and I are like breaks our heart like
we're like but it's funny to know he is
brilliant he's great he's a monster yes
that's the thing the best of their like
I'll watch like this like these little
pocket shows that are you know but or
[ __ ] wrestling or bachelor with my
wife or real house I will [ __ ] dude hop
out how about when I was it comes from
there's a poster when it was like it was
like oh the reunion back in as Robin
Williams Richard Pryor Louie Anderson
died say Robin Williams there's like all
the classics like Wow in one night yeah
it's not easy incredible nuts man you do
some kind of answer do some deference
how about those shoes are gorgeous
thanks man these boots they're these
ones are the Joseph Abboud Cheney's
Joseph Chaney boot out of England okay
it's English leather right there you
[ __ ] anyone favourite boot though anti
black and half press what just happened
on this show come inside black inner I'm
just saying my hat matches wait now what
Sven and I'm dressed like Jesus if
you're wearing a black hat we all know
what that signifies
here we go hey do you guys see Black
Panther yet I have not you know why
cause everyone's rant and rave about it
so I go the opposite
I hear you not seeing it yeah but it's
not the best thing I've ever seen but
it's awesome
I love Michael Chadwick he's great
Chadwick Boseman is so [ __ ] good
they're like he was good the black guy
was good in Robin okay we're back sorry
guys
so what do you know is there a chip
speaking of
phone silence like that I was like
speaking of I'm just kidding bring your
black guys John Jones yeah okay actually
speaking of hot guys I mean that's at
the best how's he doing let's go let's
get positive how's he doing his hearing
was today and he's officially fine
two hundred five thousand dollars and
his license was revoked that's right
good wait what other details are in
there fight because what California is
suspended but if they did if they revoke
it then everyone follow suit so well if
you can reapply at least in August when
the session is over yeah what
suspensions over and once he the big
ones what you sod is gonna do with them
in March now but there were some people
tell me I don't know all the details
chin because I was working while the
school and I can't watch these boring
ass [ __ ] cases but the thing is with
him he's in trouble because they said he
was untruthful when he's filling out
paperwork yeah and his manager slash
agent Malky forged his signature yeah
and a lot of the papers or something
called tutorials DocuSign just [ __ ]
deny he can't I'd sign on that [ __ ] son
but he's not be in person
let me see the DocuSign oh I don't know
that I just reaction yeah I was the
signatures that he was forged Oh John
didn't show up or something
who knows okay no you just didn't want
to read all that stuff and all to go
through all the protocols yeah but your
lawyer goes sign here sign here sign
here that's just like they keep making
these dumb [ __ ] errors oh here goes
here goes on john was grilled by the
commissioner martha shin whatever over
his past legal issues in his 2016 failed
drug test during the question Jones
admitted that he has never done his you
sadhus tutorials though they were signed
by him he said his management team did
them for him and forged him why would
you for - yeah well that's all it means
she's going down
Jones story still facing all right Jones
is facing a four year suspension you
sadiq case as a repeat offender
that's a big one yeah it says you saw
this in March right so they're smart
though they're gonna give him the max
right know that Max is four years from
USANA so no so it's gonna be like - so
yeah
with Margie retro that's why they're
saying oh so it's not bad for him I
don't think because everyone's freaking
out I don't think they get they throw
the book at him because I hope not I
just met with Dana white or yo dude I
know
look we you all your sources all I have
is people that are close to John that
are you know around him feeling very
confident that he will be fighting by
the end of this year I don't know any
details but that's what they have been
saying for months now like look look we
even even have a knot but I don't think
he would have taken that particular step
now if you don't he's got old schools
yeah yeah III think you fire I mean Jay
Gould some [ __ ] on his food is that I
think he's doing coke it was laced with
all this other [ __ ] that would make
sense that would make sense like to
party why are you all sweaty
I was watching cops yeah man how I was
watching cops I know I hope he comes
back I'm interested in I feel like in a
weird way I'm hearing it from the
horse's mouth with you because you know
I know you are you know you get on a
train offer training but it's always for
a really good reason and the fact that
you know because last time I was here we
were like he's done he may not know for
you know he was definitely taking
steroids now here we are going through
this whole thing right getting ready you
ready for what be there no matter what
he's not
I'm sure he's not like he's not
has he ever John doesn't John doesn't
work out like unless he's in camp he's
not in the gym every day like he's not
like Chris Weidman
really uh-oh that's always the best of
all time you should take those selfies
like look at this belly and then and
then in like six weeks you can see him
get in shape yeah and it spits out eats
glow all right yeah damn it damn you
it's not that crazy so it's like an act
you know those guys who don't need to
really study their lines yeah I stopped
hungover and then they take you all t43
yeah you're like what well yeah but
that's after years of training like I
feel like John Jones don't have years
training well he hasn't been wrestling
since he was around there you go what do
you free forward ability striking and
stuff like that he's a savant he picked
up like this it's no different than you
know how much better he would even be
though if he was there like all but I
mean well no I was watching a part of
his artistry I usually he's not I hate
when people say that guy yeah you
imagine fuse really dislike oh my god
can you imagine yeah yeah that's like
saying can you can you imagine if Kurt
Cobain never did drugs how good he admit
when I wrote scene you know part of this
how about Jim Morrison it's probably
drugs probably that man at the animal
the hole is an artist men yes you need
this he needs that like I was watching
Calvin Smith hitting it with
what's-his-name that never heard of
comes of Calvin [ __ ] all the alien in
that movie football player around 435 in
Calvin Johnson Johnson megissogwon
Megatron ran a four three five and I
think he's super big and I was when I
was like three years
yeah let's talk about these athletes
like that can the NFL and I would love
to see what someone like that would do
when there was ago he's retired played
at Georgia Tech freak freak freak Adam
on my fantasy team a few years it's so
big didn't and Matt Stafford type move
one two pods baby he always wished she
played a different team though he's kind
of liked her and more he's such a baller
but their team sucked balls but you end
up crazy numbers that doesn't mean
doesn't necessarily mean he'd be a great
fighter though right no no no this
doesn't necessarily mean that hey
Michael Jordan was great at basketball
you'd probably be good at baseball right
yeah probably good would have been a
good fight something about Michael
Jordan's hard to say though work like
saying you know so mind over matter and
so competitive I mean you know it's just
everyone get punched in the faith it's
need to be compared when you're shooting
basketball you know when you punch in
the face going yeah this is up my life I
can try to keep doing it yeah yeah be a
little bit of the socio you're right
know is the Larry Bird thing can you hit
it from here or the McDonald's
commercial oh yeah oh it's great
commercials what was that catchphrase
nothing but net from off the bat it was
like four back here it was a great
commercial off the backboard anyway
anyways fun commercial what else yeah
yeah I I don't
every one things screwed I think I'll
see the fines gonna suck and you sobs
you hit him with another two and $50,000
fine so his bank accounts gonna hurt so
he's gonna need to fight but I bet we
see him fight I'll say by them to an 18
early to the nineteen yeah I think
you're right I just can fight on that
December the New Year's card design
nominal so you know they didn't find
Dave where you tension you guys know
that they didn't find anything in the
supplements or anything right so you
guys are know that for a hundred percent
fact no yeah that's their waste of time
the supplement you know that's coca he
thought would have been great but
there's zero they had he has no alibi
what so he's either just cheating like
straight up he just what you think I
honestly don't know the straight
shooting or that cocaine thing is
reality
I like the cocaine alibi well he also
said that the Andy Foster said that he
believes him so that's a huge you know
that's a huge thing for his side that's
a hell of a tweet yeah he definitely did
not draft that and one more thing he
said was it freak I'll get back to you
there's something else that came up in
this thing when the judge said like do
you want to what do you think all your
management maybe should change
management he kind of like cackle that
it like giggled at it and that showed
his maturity at that court they were
serious about it
he was like hey I'll change it but they
actually met you should probably change
your management not a bad idea no
comment but if it's a date that weird
hearing you know you don't yeah and it's
about your thing you know that's that's
a sign of maturity to like whatever they
say like yeah I'll consider you don't
exactly or see something like my junk
you know cuz he thinks he thinks they
don't really joke in those things
yes I'll stick with my manager I really
believe in the no I'm not saying good
John I was like John might have thought
it was a joke if I'm saying he shouldn't
be shouldn't sympathetic I've had like
three hour long like deep conversations
with him the week before that fight and
was like I love him he's like my
favorite I hope he reestablishes the
throne and and he did it and like then I
texted him after and it was like amazing
and then like check Twitter one morning
he's popped again and you're like oh god
I the reason I think he's a good person
probably not I think he makes horrible
choices immature he's an amazing talent
he's the most talented man to ever enter
that octagon does he deserve to fight
yeah listen I hate to tell you guys it a
lot 95% of people with gray said I've
gone on an illegal supplements or have
previously taking illegal supplements
athletes so it's a it's part of the
sport so when I see that like alright
when when I say let me be creative let
me do his drugs then party to us think
he's still beating everyone in the world
alright what I don't want to see him be
drunk wreck into pregnant women hurt
them that's a chance that was as far as
what happened in the hot gun I don't
give a [ __ ] what that man does yeah yeah
I could give two SH and you guys are
tell me when you watch Brock Lesnar
literally beat years off mark Hunt's
life you all assumed he was clean no
where else with a bunch of guys long
called good guys all dog lalu before in
the locker room and you're like alright
it was like when Michael Vick got caught
for the pit bull thing and I have pit
bulls I love my dogs and I'm a dog guy
him but then everybody was like [ __ ]
everybody at the table Americans love
their dogs [ __ ] guys [ __ ] love dogs
man [ __ ] the guys a [ __ ] scumbag
[ __ ] that guy everything else is my
friend just good hey everybody listen I
appreciate that I like dogs - I don't
give a [ __ ] if that guy kills all the
dogs he plays on Sunday
cuz he's so [ __ ] excited what's weird
is I never forgave Vick no he never did
never did I didn't like I get it she
hated it when they told me what he did
those dogs and what they were doing or
the culture away I'm out yeah I'm
[ __ ] out a lot of people were cuz you
know I feel like I don't like that Jon
hurt that lady that's [ __ ] up yeah
that's super [ __ ] up take that away
what he's doing in the Octagon I can
forgive him yeah who does he fight when
he comes back laughs Lesnar or the
winner or if Steve a were to beat DC
fights debate but not boy fights for
Doom he what DC won't fight him no no no
DC smart Annette I'd love to see DC get
the money fight against Brock - if you
would be back this is all assuming steep
a doesn't win which is crazy see we can
beat DC steep a and John Jones make
sense everyone
they can't handle the Indonesian you
know I'll talk about
I'm sick of doubting Steve now you don't
see packs jokes all week every was in
Bennett's yeah I've never seen anyone
having like it's just a more jolly time
with it all and then Steve a timer yeah
and then he comes out and just cleans
clocks it just does work now they're
doing the Ultimate Fighter that's great
I think that like I always arrange so
care such as ah now the turnover so
quick that it doesn't put them on the
shelf how long have you watch is it no
one watches it those guys are out there
for six weeks and said they're away from
their family I feel bad Joe and I don't
make much money doing it now it's kind
of a [ __ ] show you know it like let them
train dc's doing pay-per-views he's
doing fight nights he's doing UFC to
night he pays a fireman and then you got
to do this reality show that literally
nobody watches can you train when you're
you've been on this thing can you train
when you know the days are so long can
train with some of the guys I don't
think it's heavy weights again is it
I don't I doubt it no not really you got
to coach the guys you can't regatta
coach the gets [ __ ] tough man long
days you're not getting wife's a day
five to six times a week
they need to coach up the guys there's
drama so no he says a problem
you're sure question though do you think
that like weirdly enough like with
Cormier like just staying in that
competitive mode because you know he's
gonna take it seriously he's gonna go
off full-on wrestling coach with it you
know what I mean like do you think that
almost keeps his head in the game seeing
stuff I don't know about seeing CP as
much I don't know whatever he's doing is
working
do you see Alan thing he needs that he's
an Olympian you know he does he's gonna
win no matter what neither a steep bay
neither one of them needs it this season
that it's like yeah I'm gonna be a busy
like I don't know if it to me it's a
waste of their time like what yeah you
know what let them promote the fight let
them train do the thing and just make it
a super fight this almost demisch is the
product it's a hat on a hat it's too
much don't need it well also they kind
of really like each other and it's
better when the two teams don't like
each other right I don't like each other
but you know Dee you don't this one you
don't need them to have attitude it
sells itself
like you heavyweight champ heavyweight
champ yeah I mean it's [ __ ] sells man
yeah you don't even do Tuffy the only
thing tough can do is ruin it for us
oh this is the undefeated season I know
you still don't care about it but
it's all it's lightweight and feather
weights it oh sweet small guts
undefeated though
oh no no ready small guys trained by big
guy that is and also small guys Mighty
Mouse King so I could be welter and
light heavyweight no why would you
another heavyweight why would you do a
heavy weight season I haven't had one
since season 10 I great you're the
highest ratings of all time I think you
want to see big men yes you want big man
co-chair heavyweights with rampage and
damn shot only season they've ever done
besides the season 1 season a lot of
words out there but Matt came off great
on that right yeah but think about it
that that season and also think about
now heavyweight dinosaurs no new blood
yeah got Francis who thought was a new
blood can't wrestle so we got a problem
and then you got light heavyweight the
guy with the longest now train at
heavyweight with three consecutive wins
you ready for this is Shogun yeah a
heavyweight that heavyweight I'm saying
that yeah yeah light heavy is always but
need to do Ultimate Fighter on them but
again no one watches so don't know what
else she had to last one on John Jones
what do you think the odds are that
someone sabotage him because that's the
only three things that could happen
right he cheated he didn't by sabotage
anybody mean put some some extra [ __ ] in
your cocaina your cocaina
know like someone save that Sunnyside
eggs and was like yes I'll get it's
literally a team no one's buying that
that's a really yeah this isn't [ __ ]
you know the Simpsons it's not really
what you're gonna do you know that's
like what you tell your mom that used to
work back in the day like 93
I'm like Michael Irvin got caught with
cocaine like what so implanted this like
that makes sense yeah yeah someone did
that's called the denial alum yeah
doesn't work these days we at the
Internet what does kitchen let's see
here
you know how Trump had that meeting with
the governors and he said that during
that shootout at the school he would
have ran towards the gun yeah I'm in
without a gun
Trump said that Trump yeah right I truly
believe I would have walked through
running there even if I didn't have a
gun you never put yourself in a position
in your life and then of course Dan
Rather says that makes me yeah he did
let me hear that here dan Rather 4.4
more from the mir damn how many four
deferments yeah something to do with
this foot I blamed his foot of course
you did
let me see it let me see let me see her
dan Rather sir unlike valu Tim Kennedy
said unless you run toward that sound of
gunfire shut your ignorant mouth about
me about me about the remarks that he
made referring to that he would himself
run to the school
the Parkland High School issue do you
think those were sincere gestures or do
you think that's just something an
agenda that you strategy you know what
be respectful the office of the
presidency
but when a younger Donald Trump
at chance Senate we counted you
you done boom if they need love standing
rather for sure talk faster great great
news man
yeah I know but answer faster he's being
very careful I wouldn't be surprised if
only a few people wanted to hear from
him about his great bravery and what he
might do
and others one the Great's men long time
ago was Touche
he's on the Russian or go [ __ ] yeah
waa no he got he got RKO'd by randy very
good right yeah
Tim Kenny said it best though to he goes
yeah that guy's a bit of a coward who
didn't run in there but until the boats
are fine you have no idea how you guys
right he was it's easy to say that but
yeah until you've been there so don't I
don't say [ __ ] you don't know man but
also if your that's your job identity
you should go in there I they did it I
know how many I'm about now they're
worried now there was something about
the idea that it wasn't there something
about the idea that there was there was
a standard operating procedure yeah
we're supposed to wait before you going
but if you hear gunshot believe this is
my this is my shocking in this place
that there's deputies there they have
guns they hear gunshots
no one goes in that's your job that's
literally the only reason you there is
to protect those kids I know we don't
want a suicide mission
okay man yeah that's why you're there
you think soldiers want to get shot
[ __ ] no but they have courage and they
go through it they know they they figure
it out [ __ ] you man that's your job
that's your sworn I literally that's
what you've forgotten HX not to wait
outside with the gunfire man being like
dude it's really fun hanging on the fire
to the fire alarm goes off they're like
do it this is one of the worst we've
ever seen you're the first responders a
neutral risk I might get burnt inside
like why yes of course no [ __ ] wait let
me do all this training you're supposed
to go in the time of need
I mean I spent some time as a fire I'm
not an expert in what happens if you
start fire I don't know you guys you
guys have a gun the kids don't have the
gun now it's really interesting those
guys that are like like firefighters I
mean there's the Tim Kennedy's of the
world these people obviously it's a
different class but like well I was with
some firefighters wasn't like Dave they
loved it
like when that when the bell goes off
it's like time to type they run toward
the fire Jim Kennedy wants something to
happen around him oh my god I said he
posted his adjusting his Isis come get
it right I'm not yeah no you guys around
the theater come and get it do you
solder like to go get me portly snug get
behind pulling gun at the face you know
this no yes I don't want to go test Tim
Kennedy and he saw from his window a
random car pulling up the road so he
somehow [ __ ] MacGyver and out of it
and get the beats throughout the car
with a gun
he goes what the [ __ ] you doing my
neighbor and they're like we're here to
piss test you he's like don't even come
down there without being you know on
unarmed or not telling anyone said
Kennedy you don't [ __ ] with everybody
now let's invest elite that's an elite
tier 1 commando that's a whole different
[ __ ] city right yeah also things part
of another [ __ ] - I cried long hard for
him what else we're trying he's killing
people non-stop remember last year he
said that he had forgotten that he had
700 Bitcoin from album sales yet he just
kept and then it turned out to be like 7
million or 8 million dollars yes yeah
you can't miss it was a lie so he had to
actually reveal it in court because he's
doing a bankruptcy case so they found
out that he was lying
that's embarrassed yeah yikes we have to
decide on firing the kid that was a good
one right is over the phone no business
to do oh then why did it sound so boring
I don't know I just couldn't understand
what exactly it was hard to get a
conversation going with him I think he
was tired and he was just that was right
around the time he filed for bankruptcy
yeah it's worse it's not gonna want to
talk to me yeah yeah I gotta know what
he was saying to be honest I have no
idea what I don't know he was due on the
show it really didn't make sense yeah it
was also her lowest rated shows because
like it's not out like you're like why
and he wasn't really like one of the
guys I'm really open I know and you know
that that makes sense he didn't know us
he's like the [ __ ] there's another you
know who are these people
oh come on show though it is hard to sit
here and just talk make it so easy oh
yeah oh yeah because we're impossible to
talk to yeah because we're asking the
real questions exactly as we're trying
to burn you money I said he says a real
question by the way we mailed me earlier
I'm glad we changed right because we
have an agenda here I'm writing the kid
we really outlined the [ __ ] out of it
why don't you get Jen a drug dealer got
caught he got pulled over and just put
in some of the drugs that he had in his
mouth you know they put in a little
baggies or whatever yeah he swallowed
him and then the cops actually found
some in his car so he went to jail
and then they won't leave let him leave
jail until he poops he's been in there
for 40 days and has not pooped for 40
days you could die is he constipated
Adam where's the seat or he's just
holding all that because he doesn't want
the evidence to come out he said he'd
rather die well it's gonna happen cuz
well those blues even a burst has bats
in the balloon right go go you know I
don't know what you're in it or or
heroin or Molly was when it sparks from
the acid in your stomach or intestines
and that release is in your [ __ ]
impress you gonna trip his balls and
they're gonna die I'm gonna go and
overdose for sure I'm gonna go ahead and
say he's not got any [ __ ] he's got no
drugs and he's just doing it to [ __ ]
with him what but why because you don't
know drugs he oh thanks guys
that's so silly but LT had a story about
one time he was doing GHB and he got
pulled over it's that infamous DUI you
know that wasn't actually taken at a
police precinct it's right next to a
hospital because they wanted the picture
he goes you might as well take a picture
I know that's what you're here for
let's just do it here so you'll have to
keep going with me and so yeah that's
that infamous thing that he loves crazy
[ __ ] he was on GHB that's what he used
to do like proudly he talks about this
like it's a date rape drug that people
drop like update take just enough you
feel really good and he gets sexual if
you take too much you past that wake up
with a sore ass one chap man Wow
- Nick woke up you know and once it
leveled off he was in the cell and he
was doing he was doing push-ups he was
having the greatest time and they
couldn't offer the luck cuz it's like
untraceable I think they could not buy
them like this figure out what the [ __ ]
he was on you're gonna have to tell us
at some point what you're on he's just
no one just doing like like classic
clapping after you know that's in crazy
is this glass loud enough the suggestion
I guess just last one it's just a rumor
that Conor McGregor asked the UFC to
make create a 165-pound belt yeah well
this is from bar stool bar stool and
what is taken from that guy Ali
Abdulaziz what why did he what is that
just cuz he reps
Eggar yeah cuz they're going back and
forth with I know look like that's
that's clickbait I mean
right definitely yeah and it's so
believable just like come on Garth
believe is on the barstool car washing
all their podcasts on Thursday oh that's
cool yeah I don't know I don't know if
that makes sense it's definitely click
baton
well that's it boom PAH boom boom y'all
coming up a pom pom pom pom voice of an
angel
hey can you sing can you see can you
sing every [ __ ] time um uh no no but
cannot be in Huntsville Alabama
March 8th 9th and 10th Huntsville
Alabama let's stand up life too much and
too much ocean I'm at Oxnard March 16th
Oxnard March 16 no need to be like
Huntsville Alabama Huntsville Alabama
March 8th 9th and 10th
is that a stand a blind
[Music]
damn damn it's good tomorrow at the
Melrose improv one hour oh no you can't
see your regular it's different and I
was different
sometimes I get bumped for bigger too
you know what I'm like get me a salad
fire magic [ __ ] true me my respectful
on my show Amy Schumer came in last week
I got burned
I'm liking a hoary out Skyler I'm not
gonna do that to you bro I'm not gonna
make you see my day Palm Beach Palm
Beach hit me up the big brown breakdown
gonna be called below the belt podcast
correct my is my theme song for big
brown breakdown now gonna be the you
know what I mean you know when you're in
a bind what's gonna happen there I
should have that on we might have to
retire it right now do you have to
change it boo hoo I have a good idea
okay so it's the below-the-belt podcast
with Brendon shower correct and my theme
song just the audio version of the
cartoon brings us in and then I think
there should be like a special segment
where it's more like the big brown
breakdowns gonna do no he's gonna it's
gonna be like UFC 225 like all right
chin let's bring us in sound drop let's
bring the sound drop back you took it
out for a drop in knowledge it was so
[ __ ] rude of you guys I waste a lot
of time I think Brian hated it no I did
not I loved it I those were like early
stages but now that we have two really
nice produced ones I know I think below
the belt is you know we stepped our game
up a bit for it did it in half the time
yeah we're gonna play below the belt the
theme song you did will be the start of
the show podcast and podcast and then
when you go into the segment it's just
like when you transition all right way
let's talk about some fights okay boom
then they move around
that's not a bad idea it's only a minute
long they like it so the piece so b3 is
kind of gone though you're just not gone
now we're gonna meld it we're gonna
broil with the exact same show just now
on the you'll have to risa scribe
anything it's just changing the name
below the belt Brennan shop I still own
everything
no I know but you're so when people want
to go around break down we're just
changing big brown breakdown I still
keep all my subscribers still although
the logged episode everything by the way
shout out to chin he doesn't get enough
love he's the [ __ ] man behind it all
he absolutely crushed it with the theme
song he's no bro never we started the
podcast you guessed it we've been over
there whatever I'm talking about it I
have to also say you know don't give me
a gentle fist bump like that I'm so
gentle you want you relate this I just
don't like touching you because I know
you've been like scratching your ass
yeah scarlet we love you brother you
know thank you so much man I'll be back
and later part 18 and I'm coming really
this is the fine kid we're out